I had so much emotional pain inside of
me that, you know, I I was a very
sincere Christian. But because I had so
much emotional pain, I didn't know how
to not be irritated and agitated and
frustrated. You know, um I I would hear
pastors say, "You need to have a
relationship with you need to have an
experience with Jesus. You need to be
closer to Jesus." I'm like, well, how do
you do that
when you have all of this baggage and
all of this pain? And that is what
inhibits you from being able to have the
Christlike character.
[Music]
This month, we're talking a lot about uh
the fact that people delete themselves
from life and let the hearer understand
what I'm saying here. This month is uh
dedicated to that scenario. So, do you
have any statistics on that?
Well, um, yes, I do actually. Um,
deleting yourself, it is so weird for me
to say it in that way,
is the 12th leading cause of death in
the US. So, that's that's one. I have a
few. Uh, males die by deleting
themselves. Uh, they're more uh 3.8
times more likely to die by deleting
themselves than than women. On average,
there are about
132 deaths
per day.
Per day
by people who delete themselves. And
white males actually are accounted for
seven out of 10 of of those.
Wow. 70%.
Yeah. I don't know why that is. When my
when I was looking at my statistics, I
really didn't understand why white males
are more likely. Um maybe it's because
of all the pressure from I I don't
really know why.
Maybe there I mean is it we're my my
majority. So maybe that's just the cause
or
Well, it could be that being the
majority. It also could be being in a
capitalistic society and the male do
white male dominance is more glorified
in some ways. I mean they tend to get
ahead, be more successful. They have
maybe more they have to carry. I'm I'm
not really sure. So, as a mental health
therapist, what do you think the reason
why men in general uh do this than
women?
Well, I would say because men um are
more leftrain oriented, meaning that
they don't uh sit and with their
emotion, they don't um process their
emotion a whole lot. A lot sometimes. Uh
I'm not saying all men, but uh generally
speaking, men don't even really know why
they're feeling uh what they're feeling.
Uh so as a result a lot of things can
get bottled up inside. Uh men don't
typically want to seek therapy.
Um counseling is very important.
If you don't have somebody to talk to,
you need to talk to somebody.
Um so uh a lot of men don't see the need
for a therapist. They tend to uh engulf
themselves in work.
Mhm.
And they allow that to be their therapy,
which we know that that doesn't really
work,
right? Um, and so it's it's it's more
like the left brain oriented. Right
brain is more where the holistic
feeling, emotional side is. It's not so
much in the left brain. And so,
so a lot of us are are dealing with a
lot of hardships in our life, but a
woman is more likely to seek out therapy
and get it off her chest and get some
feedback, whereas a man, he's just like,
"No, I'm going to work through it." And
right,
and they eventually just bottle up till
they can't take it anymore.
Right. On average, women speak about
50,000 words a day. Men speak about
10,000.
Wow.
If that,
you know, I think it's interesting. I
saw a uh Jubilee video and I don't
really I don't like watching Jubilee
videos cuz they're they're a mess, but
uh one of the things that they they
showed was a statistic that said that
when men um have bottled up this emotion
uh and primarily men that bottle up this
emotion, they they u have done that
primarily because while they were dating
someone and this was this was a amazing
statistic to me. while they were dating
someone in their in their teenage years.
Um, they had a female partner that when
they opened themsel up to
cancelled them because they felt that
they were weaker. And so they've they've
restricted this in their heart, maybe
even canceled their own ideas of it and
made it so that when they are they they
didn't feel like they were enough of a
man at that point. Wow.
And so to become more of a man or what
society thinks are a man, they they hide
their feelings.
I thought that was fascinating.
Well, it just brings to light how much
of an influence a woman is and helping a
man to be able to reach the top of his
ladder and to be able to be successful.
Men in their own merit generally. Yeah,
I say general because then I get, you
know, folks be upset thinking I'm saying
all men. There are some men who are able
to identify with their emotions. Most
men don't generally they don't but
generally men u find success in their
achievements.
Yeah.
And um if they have not been nurtured
emotionally that their achievements are
what will drive them. M
and so uh a woman, a good woman, a
healed woman, an emotionally secure
woman, uh can help them to be able to
identify with their emotional side and
see that as a gift from God,
not as a negative.
Yeah, I know. I often hear seems like
women are always like, "Come on, talk,
open up." You know, they want the man to
open up and you don't talk enough about
your feelings, but like what you're
saying. So, it's like a conflicting
thing of ideas. This man or multiple
situations opened up and was looked at
as weaker, but then they get involved in
a relationship and the woman wants them
to open up. So,
well, see, it's it's how you do it. So,
if you just coming out at with at the I
would never approach a man like that.
Well, you just don't talk enough.
You don't say anything. You don't
express your emotion. Okay. Well, that's
just going to cause him to shut down. M
um there are ways that you can engage
with a man to get him to open up. And
usually it's about talking about what he
likes to talk about.
So you most of the time women we when
we're engaging with men, we talk to them
like we're talking to our girlfriends.
You can't talk to a man like you're
talking to your girlfriend. You have to
be very linear cuz men think in
compartments. They're compartmentalized.
So you got to get him on his compartment
he's on. If he likes cars, talk about
cars. M
you know if he likes le talk to him
about Lilice Studios, you know, kind of
focus on enga engage him enough to know
what it is he likes and then target
that. If you target that and you start
talking about that and get him he'll
start talking and talking and talking. I
I do it all the time.
I did it with you. No, I'm just playing
with you. But I but I I could easily get
a man to talk by just focusing on him
and talking about what it is I know he
likes or what I know he will uh be
interested in talking about. Get them to
talk first
because that's what you want. You want
them to talk. We don't need to be
talking about emotions right now cuz
that's far that's far right. They're not
going to swing like that. But first just
get them to talk. Then when you get them
to talk, then you start attaching uh
emotional words to it.
So it sounds like you really like that.
Sounds like that made you feel good.
Sounds like that's something you love.
Now you start attaching words to what it
is they're talking about. Then it's you
you slowly help them to swing over into
right brain. You don't just well you're
just not talking enough. You don't say
what I you you know. No, that's he's not
your girlfriend. Mhm.
And that's it's another reason why women
uh end up being like that scripture in
Proverbs that a nagging woman is like a
dripping faucet.
Wow.
They end up being like that because
you're trying to force someone to talk
and that's not how they communicate. We
need to we need to learn to to speak in
their language.
And if you learn to speak in their
language, that's that's called being
outward focused. If you learn to speak
in their language and your outward
focus, then he will talk. But if you
just expect him to just unravel the way
that you unravel with your girlfriends
when y'all all sitting around drinking
tea,
it you're never you're always going to
get that conflict.
Mhm.
Man, this is great. This is like men are
from Mars, women are from Venus.
That's exactly what it's like.
Five love languages.
Yes. Yes. What are since we're this is
the awareness weekend of this thing or
or month, what are some red flags that
people should look for? I I think one of
the biggest things is just not knowing
because I've seen so many testimonies of
people that said, "I just had no idea
that this person would do this. They
seemed happy. You know, you see them on
social media, they're outgoing, but
inside they're dealing with something
that they're not letting the world
know." How can you pick up on that if
they're not expressing it? Is there any
kind of signs?
Yeah. See, that's the thing. like my own
experience. No, none of us knew. My my
brother deleted himself and this
happened in 2014 and none of us knew
um that he was uh going through this.
How old was he?
He was 32.
Wow.
Three boys.
Um and so we I lived in another state
and he was he was in Texas, I was in
Maryland. So it was wasn't like I could
be with him all the time. It wasn't like
I could engage with him all the time.
And so I didn't know until I got the
until I got a call. So I got a call from
my mother and my mother said, "Your
brother is talking about deleting
himself. I need you to pray." Now I, you
know, I had never had I, believe it or
not, I worked at that particular time, I
was working in a psych ward
uh overnight doing a lot of psych
assessments. And so, but I didn't think
he would do something like that. So when
I got off the phone with her, I'm just
like, he must be having a moment. This
boy acting no fool. You know, that was
all I thought.
But about maybe 10 minutes later, he
sent a text out. And when he sent a
text, see, see, going back in in my
story when I worked in the psych ward, I
had someone come in when I had just
started. So this was me just getting my
clinical license. I had someone come in
psychward and I would do assessments
overnight. And this boy came in and he
said that he wanted to um supposedly he
wanted to delete himself and he was
going to jump off jump in front of the
train in DC.
And so I um he was he presented so
normally.
So I just thought, well, I guess he was
just having a moment. Nothing's wrong
with him,
you know? He was like, no, I'm fine now.
Don't worry. I'm just going to go back
to school. Like he gave me this whole
story. And when I called, because before
I would make a decision about what I was
going to do with the client, because
once you there, if you're um talking
about deleting yourself, if you've had a
moment, depending on what level you're
at, they will make you stay. You can't
just go home.
Yeah.
It's called a 5150. So, you got to stay
and we got to send you to a psych ward.
Um
but I didn't think that that was the
case because he had presented so
normally to me. And so I um called the
psychiatrist cuz I had to call the
psychiatrist to get their approval and
tell them what I had done, the
assessment, give them the breakdown. And
she said, "You can't just send him
home."
And I said, "Why? He's fine." She said,
"He just said he was going to go jump in
front of a train and you're talking
about he's going to go home. He can't go
home." I cried almost the whole night
because I almost was about to send this
boy home because of how he looked. But
it was just such a um it etched in my
mind that when someone also he said he
was he was uh going to jump in front of
the train and one of the other things he
did is he reached out to all his family
members and said a goodbye.
Oh see
but see I this was one of my first psych
assessments that I had did in the ER. So
I didn't know.
Wow. And I had uh talked to my other
count u my other colleague and she said
this is why you could not send him home
because he reached out and you know he
gave all she gave all the plastic signs.
So that just kind of etched in my mind
that how how you relate to someone who's
putting out signals and about now going
forward to my brother about 10 minutes
after I got that call from my mother he
sent a text to all of us.
Okay.
And that's how I knew
you're reliving things now
right? So that's how I knew, oh, he's
going to do this. He's serious. So what
I did being in Maryland, I called the
county sheriff and I told them that they
needed to get to his house as soon as
possible because he's either actively
going to do this right now or he's
already done it.
So they went out and they uh got to his
house, but he wasn't there.
He had already left.
So for two hours we were on the edge of
our seat trying to figure out where is
he
and two hours later they found him at
the graveyard.
Oh
he had shot himself.
Oh that's terrible.
And so you know um and the thing about
it was when he shot himself he wasn't
dead. He was still alive.
And so then they were trying to figure
out is he going to be permanently
disabled or is he going to die?
And eventually a a couple days later
they pronounced him dead. See, in Texas,
if you're considered brain dead, you're
considered dead.
Yeah.
So, he was considered brain dead.
I think that's an important point to
bring up, and I'm I'm it's it's a sad
thing to think about, but I'm glad you
pointed that out because I've had um
friends that have deleted themselves,
and people think people that actually uh
are thinking about doing this act, they
don't realize that the brain doesn't
want to die.
And so, you think that this is going to
be an on andoff switch and you're going
to be done with this life. That's not
how it works. You're going to suffer for
days sometimes.
And uh and and and I've had friends and
friends of friends that have done the
exact same thing you have. And I hate to
say it and prolong what we're talking
about here in in that respect, but uh
whether you're taking like for instance,
men typically
use
firearms.
Firearms. Yeah. I was trying
actually that was the next statistic.
50%
and women typically use pills. Yeah. And
so they want to maintain their
appearance. Men don't really care. They
just want it out. Both of them are
extremely painful no matter what.
Especially if it doesn't work,
right? Yeah.
Now, I couldn't have imagined if he
would have not died. I'm thankful he did
die once he decided to do that because
if he wouldn't have died, he would have
been permanently disabled his entire
life,
you know? I mean, and I'm not talking
about just a permanent. I'm talking
about seriously permanent. somebody
would he would probably been like a
vegetable,
you know. So for so for his sake, I'm
I'm glad that the Lord allowed him to uh
pass away because once he decided to
make that decision, he he it would it
wouldn't have it would have been very
hard on the entire family
to to to care for him and he wouldn't
have been able to be himself at all. If
if people are saying that they're going
to do this, take it serious. Even if
they're right,
even if they're like, you know, oh,
they're just saying that,
you still have to take every situation
serious.
Well, you do. You should take everything
serious. But there there are three
things that you look for when someone's
talking about uh uh they're going to
commit suicide. Do they have an intent?
And do they have a plan?
So, if they're I mean, actually, two
things. Do they have intent? Do they
have a plan? Now, if somebody saying
they going to kill theirself, but they
they sleep in the bed, they talking
about they going to jump out off the
Golden Gate Bridge and they live in in
Texas and you talking about you want to
jump off Golden Gate. Okay. Obviously,
probably they probably won't do that.
Um, if someone's saying that they want
to take some pills,
but they don't have no medicine in the
house, you know what I'm saying? If
they're saying they want to shoot shoot
themselves, but they don't even own a
gun and don't have any access to that.
So, you know, uh you would just assess
to see, okay, do are you really serious
about this or are you trying to get
attention, but then you have those who
really do have an intent and they have a
plan and they have it all laid out and
they know exactly what they're going to
do.
Um yeah, that's who you want to be. Uh
and and someone who's reaching out.
Yeah.
Who's reaching out? If they're reaching
out, you need to act on that as soon as
possible.
Yeah. Even if even if you don't like
call the cops on them or something, take
those signs that they need somebody to
talk to, you know, if they're
even if they aren't like you said, even
if they aren't don't have an intent,
they're still reaching out in some sort
of way.
Yeah.
You know, um
when we were when I was in high school,
I remember distinctly uh they had a
group of people that came to us and they
they were teaching specifically about
this because not because anything that
happened in the high school, but because
they want to prevent it. And one of the
things I distinctly remember them saying
is ask people
ask them are you going to hurt yourself
and that that would actually bring it
out that was a softer blow than are you
going to commit the act
but um they you could open up someone a
little bit easier that way.
Right. And I that's something I ask
pretty regularly when I'm in session.
Are you thinking about hurting yourself
or others?
Um and usually they'll say no I would
never do that. I'm just really upset
right now. You know, usually people will
say, "I would never do that." And
they'll tell you why.
Because my kids or because my wife or I
would never I can never live with myself
or because God, you know, they have some
type of barrier that's keeping them from
doing that. Uh but they if they don't
have a filter, if they don't have any
type of barrier, we need to you
definitely need to be on guard. Uh there
are different cases too because uh I
know two of them uh some of my friends
brother
uh I mean that guy I mean seriously was
so active in the church singing in the
front of the church.
Mhm.
I mean you know I mean he was not like
always happy you know he was a normal
guy. I mean seriously no like he had a
nice girlfriend stuff like that. The
situation is that it was a fight in the
in the relationship with the girlfriend
and he couldn't handle it
and they found him
just I don't know what to say the word
but like you know hanging there
and that was very sad like are you
kidding me like that's not an answer I
mean he was a nice Christian guy I'm not
kidding you
met him and I when I get the news I was
like no way what are you talking about
like like like he was not mean guy. He
was not listening this crazy music. He
was not doing part, you know, anything,
right?
But he just like
I mean I don't know in those in those
moments that
they cannot handle themselves, I guess.
I mean that huge situation with the
relationship or whatever problem they
just react like that.
Well, because you know men want to be
the hero.
That's their goal. Um and they want to
make the woman happy. One one of the
ways that a man is a hero is by making
his woman happy. That's one of the
things I always hear a man say when they
with a woman, I just want her to be
happy.
I just want her to be happy. So, if
you're having this, if you if you love
this woman so dearly and you're not able
to make her happy and nothing you're
doing is making her happy, they feel
like a failure.
And um the the the the gradations for
how much you feel like a failure vary.
You know, some people they're already
over the edge and not feeling like a
failure in that one area. Maybe he
wasn't able to succeed, didn't feel like
he was successful in all the other
areas, and now he's getting into an
argument with his girl, and that throws
him throws him over the edge. I mean,
it's very important. I I one of the
things that that I I grieved about,
I didn't even grieve about my brother as
bad as I grieved about the fact that
there were so many things that I could
have said to him, so many different
times where I could have been a good
influence to him. And because I didn't
know what I know now, I never was.
I remember one time he called me and he
could have been I don't know what he was
thinking or why he called me, but you
know, we had this contankerous
relationship. We never would never talk.
We were just always fighting about
something cuz we boy, girl,
Mars, Venus, you know, just always our
parents didn't really bring us up. They
didn't know how to bring us up to get
along. So when we got into arguments, we
would just fight. But we loved each
other so much. We loved each other
dearly. And I remember one time he
called me and I and I said, "What are
you calling me for?" That's what I said.
And he said, "Um, you're a bad sister."
Wow.
And I I just that that that has never
left my mind.
It's so important how we treat each
other
and how we treat the man. I as a woman,
it is very important. your words, what
you say. A you can walk into a woman's
house and you know if a woman lives
there,
her essence, her sense, her influence,
it permeates throughout the whole house,
good or bad,
you know, and the men, men, they may not
say it, they may not verbalize it, but
they can feel it.
And it's so important that we give off a
positive influence, you know, and the
only way you can really do that is with
Jesus. So if you got your own hurt and
your own pain, you know, you got to heal
from that stuff because you're you're
you're kind of breaking him down
emotionally with your words and the way
you treat him,
you know, and he's not going to come
out. All he's just trying to do is make
you happy.
We all influence each other. And I think
that's the that's one of the main points
we bring out here at Little Studios is
no matter what, if you are a live with
person next to you or if you're watching
it on TV,
that will affect you. And that's why I
always tell people, hey, I don't want to
watch that. I want to hear that drama. I
don't want to hear it in the other
bedroom because I've I've got my own
issues. I'm going to I'm going to work
out. I don't need someone else's, too.
So, I don't need the drama happening on
soap operas in my house, and I don't
need to hear about it because it's going
to affect me and cause me even more
trouble in my life.
Yes. Yes. And so, yes. Well, by
beholding, we become changed. And I'm
focusing on the woman cuz that's where I
live and I know how much of an impact it
is. I I talk to men all the time. I'm in
session with them. I'm in marriages all
the time. And when I start to help the
woman to talk to him in certain ways,
his whole attitude changes.
Wow.
He can start to come out and what you're
saying you want. You want them to talk,
but you're beating them down with your
words,
right?
And and it and and it's to no fault of
our own to some degree because that's
what we saw.
Yeah. You know, I w it wasn't modeled to
me how to treat a man or how to
communicate with a man or what to say to
him when he was feeling down or not to
uh emasculate him or make him feel less
than a man. I I was never shown how to
do that in my parents' marriage. They
did the best they could, but
unfortunately they didn't model that cuz
they didn't know,
you know. So, we bring these in to our
relationships and we think that we're,
you know, we're doing a great job, but
really it could be very hurtful to the
other person. And men are macho. So,
they're not going to say
that hurt my feelings. You know what I
mean? Typically, they don't say use
words like that.
I don't have the references, but the
Bible talks about the tongue being this
small member, and it can really do a lot
of damage. It's like a sword. Um, the
power of life and death is in the
tongue. I mean, the Bible's full of
wisdom on this. Your words have power.
They can really hurt people.
And and a woman's influence
in the Bible, you can see how a woman's
influence can deter
Oh, yeah.
a man. Y
you know if you look at Solomon, if you
look at Samson and Delilah, if you look
at David and Basheba, if you look at
Adam and Eve,
the whole world coming under
destruction,
Abraham
is because he was following after her.
Cuz he wanted to make her happy.
But also, if you look at the the
opposite of it, what what can happen
when a man when a woman has a good
influence on a man? Look at David and
Abigail. Mhm.
He was going after Nabal. He was going
to take him down.
It was going down. And she came ahead
and she said, "You are a king." He He
wasn't even a king yet. But she said,
"You are a king and I know that you
would never do this."
Wow.
This isn't who you are. That's what she
said. And that's what changed his whole
attitude.
What about um the uh what was his name?
The the Roman ruler that washed his
hands clean of Jesus. You know, his wife
was
Was that Caiaphas?
Pilot.
Yeah. Pilot. And the wife was like,
"Don't do this. I have a dream about
this man." You know?
Yep.
And so our our female intuition when we
are connected to the Lord and when we're
hearing from the Lord, it can totally
change his whole attitude and bring him
closer to Jesus. See, the man is already
the head. He's the priest of the home.
But the w the woman is designed. She's
put there not just to wash your dirty
draws and cook your meals. I mean,
that's nice.
She's put there for that, too. To help
help you, help you out. And you both do
that together. Help each other out in
different ways around the house and all
all all those other things. But that's
not it. That's not just it,
okay? Anybody can cook, anybody can
clean, anybody can wash laundry. Why are
you really put in a relationship as a
woman? You're put there because you have
an influence.
you have an influence and it can change
the tide of what direction he goes
because sometimes men are not as
intuitive
because they're not his right brain. We
have this holistic sense. Women, we can
pick up what everybody feeling and what
we feeling. We just know.
Yeah.
You know, whereas men, they know how to
work gadgets and to work things, but
they don't necessarily know feelings as
much.
Oh, yeah. That's so true. Like even like
men often miss uh you know opportunity
with a woman cuz they're just not
picking up the signals or whatever. Like
if she like me, she would have said it
or whatever.
Yeah. They need real something to be
real clear for them to
you know they're not able to really
always read between the lines.
It's sad too cuz I think society has
kind of trained this idea. I don't think
it's innate or genetic necessarily.
Maybe a little bit. But if you look in
schools, you constantly you're bered at
least at man as a man growing up.
He's a sensitive man. Oh, don't be a
sensitive man. Be a macho man. You know,
you got to be the Bronny man. You know,
and uh and and so it's it's drilled into
us even from a very young age that
sensitivity and feelings are not
something you necessarily even need to
think about.
It's weakness.
It's weakness. Not really though.
Right. And so we have we have just uh um
men who are naturally leftrain dominant
just you know that's just how they're
they're born. And then we also have uh
nature that tells you that you can't be
sensitive.
You can't cry.
Crying is weak.
You're a punk
if you cry. That's punk.
You you're not supposed to do that.
You're not supposed to show emotion,
you know. And so you have both of those.
The odds are against you. All you want
to do is be this macho man and that's
it.
You just want to be a hero. And then you
got comics and you know superheroes and
you know if you the Hollywood has played
this whole thing out for for us very
well. What is the superhero wants to do?
Save the girl and save the world.
You know so men are brought it. They
don't look they don't show him crying in
his room cuz his his toe hurt.
He not crying. He not upset. He's just
always macho. And nobody can always be
on like that.
Yeah. Or it's the extreme polar
opposite. You got that but then you got
Al Bundy who's just like works and oh
hates his wife and Yeah. like the Homer
Simpson and all that and the women are
the really the leader
and the man just like, you know, deals
with it, hates his wife and all,
right? And that's what happens when you
don't have the healthy influence of a
woman. A man ends up being one or the
other. He ends up being completely
passive
or he ends up being very angry and
resentful. There's no balance
there. Yeah, that's that's true. That's
true. Yeah, there is a lot of balance
especially just when coming in as a
marriage couple because you have to
integrate those two things together. I
remember when I married my wife, we
talked to a lot of different counselors,
not just not going there because of our
problems, but because we knew a lot of
people and they always said, well, you
know, year seven or year 10 is your
hardest or it's not necessarily actually
our hardest was probably year one. Mhm.
We had to figure out if uh having that
towel on that rack beside the other one
was a big deal or not. You know, making
sure that um hey, when you cook food
that you wash the dishes immediately and
and you get that all all taken care of.
That was with integrating two lives
together is is always a polishing
motion.
Polishes both people.
Yeah. Absolutely.
Should cause balance, you know, when you
bring the two together. It's like the um
I hate to use the word ying and yang,
but it's like you're you're you're
filling each other's gap or whatever,
right? Together, you make a hole.
But unfortunately, in these marriages
these days,
we're tearing each other apart. So much
that so that we have now this toxic
masculinity where men don't even want to
get married, right?
You know, they don't want to marry women
because women have become more dominant
over men and they tower over them. It's
there's this role reversal
and then they
and it never had to be that men men
should have never been dominant over
women either.
Mhm.
Before the before we got kicked out of
the Garden of Eden, we were equal.
Yeah.
We both had equal roles.
He was the king, she was the queen. We
were both equal.
And what turned the tide was sin.
And God wants to get us back in our
relationships, in our marriages back to
the Garden of Eden. It is possible.
Yeah. you know, and one of the ways that
he can do that is by helping the woman
to heal so that she can be that strong
influence in his in his life to help him
to really follow the Lord and hear the
Holy Spirit. Um, and so that he's not
overcome with this depression, this
sadness, this anxiety that he's not
expressing.
Yeah.
You know, like I said, like you were
saying, women, we will talk about it.
We'll share. I look, I'm not going to be
sad for too long. I'm not going to be
feeling any kind of way for too long.
You going to know how I'm feeling. You
You won't even have to hear it. You'll
feel it.
Yeah. Right.
You know,
slam the door.
But men,
they don't It's not always It's very
obscure sometimes. But one of the ways
that they do kind of show is they'll
either hide themselves in different
things, different addictions, hidden
addictions, escapism,
video games,
video games. Uh when when my clients Oh,
he he never wants to talk to me. He's
always playing his video game. That's
because he's probably trying to get away
from you.
What is it that's being said in a
relationship? What's the communication
like that he's he's he's drawing away
from the relationship? And it's not all
her fault. I'm not saying it's all her
fault, but there's some communication
issues there.
You know, um the work men will drive
themsel in work when they're not happy.
They will drive because they got to find
something to fulfill themselves.
So, if it's not video games, it's work.
Some sort of hobby. I remember my father
when uh I was young used to go out and
play golf all the time. He used to
always play golf.
It's the most boring game. It's the most
boring thing.
I think that game was created for men to
escape their wives. It was Yeah. Cuz
women know it's boring.
Nine hours. How does it take 9 hours to
walk around?
What woman do you know that says, "Hey,
I want to go with you." No.
No. Nobody wants to go out there.
And I didn't want He had me go with him
one time and it was very boring. But you
know, uh, sports, um, gaming, uh, sex,
pornography,
get caught up in a lot of pornography,
um, and, uh, work, you know, hanging out
with their friends, drinking, all these
behaviors, these escape. If you're doing
these things on a regular basis and you
don't want to be home, that's a signal
to me, what's going on?
No.
What's going on? are you not? You know,
because most of the time the man isn't
gonna say how he really feels because he
feels like he's gonna get beat down.
So, he's not really able to say it. And
these things build up and they cause uh
emotional disorders, anxiety,
depression, all these things are
building up
and he's not able to express it
which can lead to what we're bringing
awareness
which can can lead to deleting yourself,
canceling yourself, taking yourself out.
Yeah. Uh, another thing is the, you
know, you hear these young kids, they're
deleting themselves, what they're
watching
and I mean, they're like 13 or bullying
at school.
I mean,
bullying is very a big thing
and it's it's very young. I mean, you
hear
online bullying.
Yeah, exactly. Online bullying. Yeah. So
yeah, I've heard I when I looked up the
statistics for um young people, it was
like only 500 and something a year I saw
from ages it was like uh uh it was like
I don't even know the exact ages. I
don't want to give the numbers, but it
was not low. It was pretty low.
The highest one, which is why I'm
sticking to the men, is it was the men.
Um it wasn't the women. It was it was it
was not the teens and it was not the
little kids. We're hearing about that
more and more and I think that's because
of media.
Yeah.
And it is happening and it's it's it's
definitely adding up way more than it
ever used to be.
It never used to be at all. I mean, we
never when we was young, we never talked
about taking yourself out. You look go
play outside or something,
you know, but not doing that,
right? Cuz I was actually shocked to
hear how old your brother was cuz I was
thinking, man, he's got families.
uh you know, you kind of get past the
depression, teenage angst years or
whatever. And to me, it seemed like,
man, you got a lot more
to live for.
Yeah. It gets better. I mean, I've seen
a lot of a lot of teenagers, oh, I got
all this stuff and I got all this and
they have all this uh emotion and they
have all this hormones, right? You know,
as you get older, things get better.
It levels out.
It levels out. And that's why it's it is
kind of surprising that your
your brother did that at such a late
age.
But that's actually more common when it
comes to the statistics.
The men.
Yeah. You know, um
but I could see it in the youth too
because they just but they the youth
statistics were just not as high. But
they are going through a lot.
It's probably just promoted more and
that's why it seems like they're the
ones that are doing it more.
Yeah. But I think they are. you know,
these statistics were back in 2020 cuz
you know, the US census and different
things,
they only come out every few years. So
perhaps in the next statistical round,
it'll be a little higher uh for the
youth, the young the
I believe it will because if you look at
what what's going on in the youth and
they're so confused about everything,
their gender and all that and they're
making these rash decisions like
mutilating your body beyond repair.
There's going to be a lot of those
people that are gonna say
I mean they're going to be going through
some very
thoughts like that, you know.
Yep. I agree.
Dangerous feelings.
You had some I forgot.
Oh, no. I do remember. So, I think it's
interesting to to that it's so important
that you brought earlier to listen to
what people are saying
because um I there was a when I was in
high school, I I had a a favorite band,
Lincoln Park. The guy died. He deleted
himself
and uh the and if you listen to the
lyrics of all those songs, Chester was
his name and he was calling it was a
call out for help and I almost feel
guilty because you listen to him all the
time you think oh yeah he's just singing
you know how many times he had to sing
that song I mean how much that is
infecting his mind himself not only
everybody else
but um
it's it's it's important to listen to
what people are saying
what they're giving off.
Yeah. But that's the thing too like with
with Lincoln Park versus you know Jeremy
Camp or some Christian singer is like
they're talking about their pain
and people can identify with that and
that's why people like
Billy Isish and stuff they're like oh
you know I can identify with her but
where is the hope
right
she's actually putting out a dangerous
message when she says like that she's
considering these dangerous thoughts
whereas the Christian singer is saying
hey I went through all this God was
right there with me and and and there's
hope. You know,
there's the answer in the song, whereas
Chester never gave that answer. And you
probably could identify with, you know,
all the time. I say that all the time.
They sing about stuff that that really
matters. What does that even mean? I
mean, you know, I I said that all the
time.
If there's no answer or no hope,
there's no hope. Yeah.
Well, that's the truth. Being able to
know who you can lean on. I mean, look
how depressed at times David was. Yeah.
You know, but he was able to lean and
focus on Jesus.
Yeah. When you read the Psalms, it's
like he was very,
I'm depressed. I'm depressed. I'm
depressed. But
I love your law and you're always with
me and don't take the Holy Spirit from
me and all these things. Yeah.
And someone who is depressed to the
degree that they cancel themselves, they
are hopeless.
They don't see any hope.
And so it takes having the Holy Spirit.
Yeah. Um, and if you don't have that,
you're that's what's going to happen.
My brother didn't unfortunately have a
strong relationship with the Lord.
Um, and and you know, he he wasn't able
to lean on that. And and one of the
reasons why is because it goes back to
my childhood. my my brother was very
close to my father and um my father died
and when my father died he just didn't
really know how to resolve it because my
father was who he spoke to all the time.
So when we talk about them getting their
feelings out he did that through my dad.
And that's why it's so important that
parents train up their child to have a
relationship with the Lord.
Yeah.
So that they know who to lean on if
you're not around,
you know. And because that wasn't model
for him, he really didn't have an
outlet.
How did your father die?
He died from u my myotus plastic
syndrome.
Okay. So he didn't delete himself.
No, he didn't delete himself. So he died
and it but it was sudden
and my brother was very close to him. We
all we you know I was close with him
also. Um but my brother was very close
with him and that was his outlet. He
said he told my father everything. M
and to have that being taken from you
and not really know where who to lean
on, you know, it's it's hard for someone
who is only who has found their comfort
and their validation in a person to lean
on Jesus because you can't see him.
And this is why parents have to model
that for their children. They got to
teach them how to pray. They got to
teach them how to seek the Lord. They
got to teach him them how to have a
relationship with him. And uh
unfortunately since that wasn't modeled,
he didn't have he wasn't able to swing
over.
And that's why it's so important for
Christians to be a reflection of Jesus.
Yes.
We might not be able to see Jesus
physically, but you should be able to
look at this Christian and say there's
something about you that I I can sense
the love of Christ in you. We should be
able to be a living example of Jesus,
right?
They don't I mean so many Christians
today are lukewarm, right? And the world
can't even look towards Christians.
They're no different than they are.
Right? And we got to be able to heal
from our stuff so that we're able to
have the character of Christ
because I mean, I know that I I had so
much emotional pain inside of me that,
you know, I I was a very sincere
Christian, but because I had so much
emotional pain, I didn't know how to not
be irritated and agitated and
frustrated. you know, um I I would hear
pastors say, "You need to have a
relationship with you need to have an
experience with Jesus. You need to be
closer to Jesus." I'm like, "Well, how
do you do that
when you have all of this baggage and
all of this pain?" And that is what
inhibits you from being able to have the
Christlike character,
you know. And so that is what one of the
things have uh one of the the going
through this whole experience with my
brother um and healing myself. Now I
have the Now I have the um I know that I
didn't know any better. You know what
I'm saying? I really didn't have the
tools myself to be able to be a nice
person so that when you call me I don't
say what you call me for.
You know what I'm saying? Like I can
actually be nice, you know, and hey,
what's going on? You all right? You
know, say stuff like that,
you know? But because I was just so
inhibited emotionally, I didn't have the
tools to be nice,
you know. And that is really sometimes
the driving force for us not being able
to act like Christians.
Everybody can say you need to act like a
Christian.
But what about when you got trauma and
when you have unresolved emotion? You
don't it's not that you don't want to
be.
You really don't know how to be.
And we're we're not talking about that
in a mental health field.
And this is why people are deleting
themselves.
And it's not being addressed. Mental
health isn't being addressed. We can
tell you up tell you blue in the face
what you need to be eating,
how to take care of your body, what
natural remedies to use, but we're not
talking about mental health.
That's true.
What about when someone's going through
serious emotional pain and they're not
able to control their thoughts?
Can we tell them how to connect with
Jesus? How to actually do that? Are we
doing that ourselves?
You know, one of the things I think is
is really helpful, and I don't know what
the solution is. you you as a a
therapist probably know better than I
do. But one of the things I thought that
that really encouraged my um mental
health was when I went out and helped
other people.
That's a good point.
I took the focus off myself and how
terrible my situation was or I thought
and when I went out and saw other people
even went on even trips to places that
were a lot poorer than I was even around
town or other countries. I realized that
this is wow, I have a castle, you know.
Wow, it's it's awful. It's awful out
here. And uh these people are happy.
Yeah.
And um why is it that I'm not? Number
one, I'm I'm helping other people.
Number two, I'm using my muscles,
increasing my endorphins. Number three,
I'm I'm active. I'm out in the sunlight
and I'm getting my vitamin D and it's
changing my metabolism and all this
other stuff.
It's amazing how how much that helps.
Well, yeah. being outward focused
instead of being inward focused. So the
the only way that you can get to a place
where you're actually going to delete
yourself is because you're inward
focused
right
with all your emotional pain, all your
issues, all your grief. Uh someone who
wants to delete themsel hates themsself.
You don't hate others. You're not you're
not hating others outwardly. That's
outward anger. It's inward anger. And
it's because of grief, sadness, and it
causes all this depression and guilt.
And what that eventually leads to is
death.
The wages of sin is death. And so when
we're focused, it's depression and all
of that. It's it's it's sinful. I know
we don't want to say that. And you know,
it's not something that's socially
accepted. We coddle. We tend to coddle
it, but we need to be real about it,
right? And there there's a level of it
that is inward focused is focused on me.
And as a result of that, you end up um
hating yourself, having all this inward
guilt that you can't deal with, that you
don't know how to deal with, and you
want to delete yourself. We have to be
outward focused,
right?
Outward focus. That's one step. It's not
the complete full paradigm, but it
definitely is one step. being able to
see other people uh um help other people
who are in a worse situation than you
are.
You know, I heard this some testimonies
that um a person they didn't, you know,
delete themselves and say, "Oh, because
that morning
some lady smiled to me."
Wow.
A
I mean sometimes that's what uh
sometimes we say like how I can help.
you know, you don't have to at least a
smile to that person because you never
know that the other person
is in the bank or in the streets or on
the bus or or anything like that.
They're going through that smile like,
"Oh my goodness, somebody just smiled to
me, man." And
couple years ago, everybody had the
mask, right?
You didn't know if they're painful, they
were happy or they were, you know what
I'm saying? like
you want to say say hi and you're like
you
say hello or something but believe it or
not just that simple thing is can be so
powerful for the other person.
It can just smile.
In fact, did you know that the Secret
Service when they're following around
the president? They can tell if
someone's going to be upset and do
something bad to the president simply by
reading. First they do is they read
their smile. If they're not happy, if
they're not clapping, if they're sitting
there like this right beside it, they
focus on that one guy the entire time
because they are concerned. People, it
really affects other people. What you do
and how you are. Even if you're just in
your mental state and unhappy, it
affects everybody around you. You don't
even realize it. Well, you know, in
Genesis when when Adam was creating all
the birds and the animals and all that,
the the thing that the Lord said was,
"It is not good for man to be alone."
The Lord did not create us to be com
focused on oursel. He created us to
reach out. He created us to connect. He
created us for connection.
Yeah.
You know, and so we were made to reach
out. That's healing to the mind, you
know. And there are people who are
struggling. You don't know what their
issues are. just simply saying hi.
You know, we go to church all the time
and people who don't look like us, that
aren't in our circle, we don't reach
out.
Reach out to somebody who doesn't
doesn't look like the normal person that
usually comes in there.
Yeah.
Extend extend a hand to them and say,
"Hey, how you doing? Just wanted to say
just want to say I'm glad you're here."
Yeah. Hey, it worked for me, man. I when
I came back to Christianity and started
visiting churches, uh I'm so thankful
that the one I chose, I mean, I was
walking in there looking totally
different. I mean, big old gauges in my
ears and tattoos and and uh not dressed
up, you know, and people would say,
"Hey, man. Is there anything I can pray
with you about?" And I'm like, "Well, I
got this going on. Let's pray right
now." And like pray with me in the
hallway. And I was just like, "Whoa."
Like I thought it was just going to be
like, "Yeah, I'll be praying for you
later or something."
Yeah.
Yeah. Those were big things. They're so
little. They seem so little. Like, "Oh,
I'm just going to pray with somebody."
It can totally change
everything in your life. My daughter,
same way. Like we go into Walmart or
whatever and and people are walking out
and she goes, "Hi." And they're like,
"Oh, hey." You know, I'm like, "Lily,
you just made that person's day."
Like people don't even I said, "Really?
Adults should be doing this, too." But
like people don't even talk anymore.
Yeah. And just the fact that she smiles
and says hi and they're just like so
taken off guard, but they can't help but
smile and say hi back.
Yeah. Well, you know, the focus should
be when you see someone who doesn't look
like you and they're not acting like
you, the focus should be on how you can
minister to that person's needs,
not cancel them out.
Yeah.
We need to stop canceling people out
because they don't look like you or they
don't act like you or they don't talk
like you or they don't say something
that you would say, you know, or they
don't fit the norm, they don't fit the
the mold. so so to speak. Um we need to
that's an opportunity to minister to
that person's needs because if they're
not um if they're not following in the
direction the straight and narrow,
there's a reason they're they're they're
missing something
and they need help. And so where can you
minister to them? Not look for an
opportunity to shut them out. We need to
figure out a way that we can include
them include them.
Yeah. There's so many people that that
they won't even consider going to church
because they've seen how they've been
treated by supposed Christians and how
churches have,
you know, treated them badly and been
hurt by the church, you know,
right?
I think as as as a Christian, we have
the duty, right?
Yeah.
I mean, if we have relationship with
with the Lord, our duty is like, you
know, to to seek the the ones that that
are like way out there in the corner or
something like that. So, like you were
saying, like taking our our eyes to
ourselves or or look at me or whatever.
I think we need to go back to our
churches and
uh he go says like, "Hey, you know what?
We need to go say hi to those people
that they haven't met them or or say
hello or something." You know,
Jesus said, "What you've done to the
least of these you've done to me."
Right?
You know, the good Samaritan story, that
guy was hurt and people were just, "Nah,
he's different than me." But it was the
Samaritan who they didn't even get
along. He was the one that helped them
out, you know.
Right.
Yeah.
And also asking the Lord to make you
aware of any in any way that somebody
could be hurting.
Amen.
You know, somebody who who looks like
they got it all together,
you know, they just the classic just
perfect person, right? Um ask him to to
make you aware of things that are
hidden, you know, um that maybe we can't
see so you can know what to pray for. I
mean, there's only so much we can do.
Uh we you it's not our duty to save
everybody,
right?
But uh the Lord sometimes can use you as
a vessel.
Amen.
Uh speaking of um reaching out to people
and having those uh interactions with
people that we need to those positive
interactions that we need to teach uh be
with everyone every day, we have an
amazing way to teach more people by just
by just uh
wearing something. Wear your witness. A
lot of people, you know, you go into
these shops and there's so so much
negativity.
There's so much negative clothing. Well,
you can go to
lightwear.shop.
Lightwear.shop. And you can pick
something out that not only is positive,
but also you wear your witness. And so,
I think that's that's a huge goal.
Amen.
And don't forget to help us spread the
message, this important message on
patreon.com/ittlelight
studios. We can only do this with your
uh funds and we can't do this without
you. So, we appreciate it.
Amen.
That's true.
So, if somebody's struggling and they're
watching this program and you say that
this is important for people to talk to
somebody, can they talk to you or do you
have resources for them?
I do have resources and yes, they can
talk to me. My ministry and practice is
called compliment and complete. And the
whole purpose of compliment and complete
is to allow Christ to complete you
because we use so many different things
to complete us and they never fill us
up. Uh but Christ is the one who
completes us. And so the whole purpose
of the ministry is to help women who
struggle with anxiety, disorganization,
um uh depression. Um those are just some
of the some of the things trauma
to help them to understand the roots of
their issues. And um I do have a women's
retreat coming up. It's going to be in
person and virtual in May. And so we are
going to be helping women to understand
how to communicate with the man, how to
communicate in marriages, how to
communicate in relationships that so
that you can know how to build someone
up. But in order to build someone up,
you got to heal from your own stuff. So
we'll be also teaching you how to rely
on Jesus, how to connect with the Lord.
That's the retreat. But we also have um
biblical counseling programs and we have
resources, free resources. I make all
kinds of um digital downloads that you
can use as your as in um for journaling.
I'm big into journaling. Uh so I have a
prayer journal. I have free biblical
downloads that you can use for Bible,
Bible study, and all different types of
resources for you to help you so that
you start to write out your thoughts,
start to heal and connect with Jesus and
learn to hear the voice of God and heal
from emotional pain.
Wow, that's a website.
Yes. Complimentandcomplete.com.
complimentcomplete.com.
Yes.
Praise the Lord. Thank you so much for
those resources. Thank you for being a
guest with us, Denra. If you like this
uh message, if it was a blessing to you,
please click the thumbs up. It's such a
simple and easy and a free way to help
this ministry. It gets the video out
into the algorithm. We want everyone to
see this message cuz we don't want
anyone to do anything that's going to
harm themselves. And we want to be able
to teach people how to look for these
signs and offer resources like this. And
if you're new, subscribe. And we will
see you guys next week on LED Live.
Bye.
[Music]
Hey. Hey. Hey.
Damn.
Boom.
There has been very few movies in the
history of the world that have
completely changed our world. And in
1999, a movie titled The Matrix hit the
world stage. These stories are often
told and seen over and over again. Is it
simply just to make money or is there
something more nefarious behind it?
Heat. Heat.
[Music]
Heat.
Heat. Heat. N.
[Applause]
[Music]
Heat. Heat.